ANTONIO FUENTES: Hi, my name is
Antonio Fuentes and I'm a
product manager at Google.
Part of my job is to make sure
that developers have a great
experience when building
applications
that use Google APIs.
Today, I will show you some
of the tools and services
available to Google developers
to get started quickly,
including how to sign up and use
an API, how to make simple
calls and calls that use
authentication, and how to get
started building code
in minutes.
We will start with a simple
background after which we will
go through the steps that any
developer would go through
when building an application
that uses Google APIs.
We will actually build a very
simple application to
illustrate these steps.
We will talk about the tools
available to explore the
functionality of Google APIs,
tools available to learn about
authentication, how to obtain
credentials to identify your
application.
We'll also talk about how to
manage access and traffic for
your application.
And finally, we will use a
simple example to start
writing code.
First, a little bit about
who this webinar is for.
This is a beginner 101
style webinar.
We assume that you
know our program.
The example we will use is in
Python, but the principles
apply to any programming
language.
We will target a developer who
has little experience coding
with Google APIs, but who likes
to dive in and learn by
experimenting.
It is also important to make the
distinction of which APIs
this webinar applies to.
Google has about 100
public APIs.
We're going to focus on
the RESTful APIs.
REST has become a standard for
surfacing data and is well
understood in the developer
community.
These APIs are simple to use
and are built on the HTTP
protocol and the API surface
resources that can be
manipulated with HTTP verbs.
And resources are nothing but
a document living at a URL.
In the case of these Google
APIs, these documents are
written in JSON.
Many API Google offers
are RESTful.
Some examples include Google+,
Calendar, Blogger, Latitude,
and many others.
In our example, we will be
using the Google+ API.
So let's say I would like to
build an application to
display my Google+ public posts
and information in them.
In today's example, we will
focus on requesting the data
from Google+.
But you can later use the
principles you learned with
any other Google RESTful API.
One key distinction is that I
want to build an application
that can access the data from
the end user who is logged in.
So, for example, if I go to my
Google+ profile and I type in,
I am excited about IO, and share
it as a public post,
those are exactly the kinds of
posts that I would want to
retrieve with my application.
Let's look at the basic steps
we will follow to build an
application that uses
a Google API.
First, I would probably want to
know if Google+ has an API,
and what it looks like.
So we will start by
exploring the
functionality of Google APIs.
Since I want to access data
for the end user of my
application who is logged in,
we will also want to learn
about authentication.
Next, we will learn how to
obtain credentials and
identify my application before
making API calls.
We will also learn how to manage
access and traffic for
the application.
And finally, we will write and
run a simple application.
So let's start with
the first step.
How do I learn about
Google APIs?
Does Google+ even have an API?
And what does that
API look like?
The first tool we will use is
the Google Developers Portal.
Google Developers is a central
location, a one-stop shop,
where you can not only learn
about Google products,
services, and tools, but also
things like developer events,
hangouts, news, use cases,
success stories, and so on.
Today, we will be using the
Google Developers Portal to
learn about Google APIs.
And in particular,
the Google+ API.
Read the documentation for
Google APIs, explore API
semantics, and try Google
APIs and get
started coding quickly.
This is what the Google
Developers Portal looks like.
It contains news, links to
documentation, hangouts, and
many other resources
for developers.
You will notice that on top of
all the information available
on the main page, there's
a search box.
And this is Google, after all.
I'm going to click on the search
box and type in the
name of the API that
I'm looking for.
In this case, the Google+ API.
I see that there's an API for
Google+, and that there's a
link to the documentation.
The documentation for the
Google+ API is structured the
same way as the documentation
for other RESTful Google APIs.
There is a main landing page
where you can learn about
general concepts that apply
to the API, such as quota,
authorization, API calls,
data formats,
pagination, and so on.
On the left nav, you can find
links to the resources exposed
by the API.
Here I can see that the Google+
API has People,
Activities, and Comments
resources.
I will select the People
resource to look at the
documentation for that
particular resource.
I see that there is a Get, a
Search, and a List By Activity
method for the People
resource.
Each method has a documentation
page, and this
is how I will navigate
to them.
I'm going to click on
the Search method
for the People resource.
And the documentation for the
Search method tells me the
HTTP request format
to make a request.
It also tells me about
parameters, and how to define
and request body if
one is required.
It also tells me what the
response of the API would look
like and what all the
parameters mean.
Better yet, the documentation
shows me code examples in a
variety of languages that
I can simply copy and
paste into my code.
The documentation also allows me
to make my own API calls by
providing a tool right there
on the documentation.
I'm going to search for my own
profile to see how this works.
I'm going to enter the name of
my profile that I've created
for this presentation and make
an API call using this tool.
Uh-huh, I see that as expected,
the API returns JSON
structure using the response
parameters I saw in the
documentation.
I can even click on the link in
the response to look at the
Google+ profile it returns.
And I see that it
is my profile.
Now, what if I want to
see the other methods
available for this API?
I can find them using the left
nav on the documentation.
I see that every resource
available for this API has a
series of methods.
Alternatively, I can use the
APIs Explorer, which is linked
to on this main page.
The APIs Explorer is
the second tool
we'll be using today.
The APIs Explorer is a tool
that allows you to, among
other things, list all available
RESTful Google APIs,
explore methods, require
parameters, including checking.
which of those parameters
are required.
Make API calls using an
interactive tool, and actually
examine the HTTP response.
And send authenticated request
calls that fetch
data owned by a user.
The Google APIs Explorer was
built using the Google APIs
Discovery Service, which we
introduced last year.
This is what the APIs
Explorer looks like.
It has a directory-style listing
of all the Google
RESTful APIs.
Using the APIs Explorer, I will
locate the Google+ API,
which is the one I'm using
in my application.
The Explorer will immediately
show me all of the resources
and methods available
for that API.
Let's try to search for
public activities.
I would go to
plus.activities.search method
and perform a query.
The Explorer shows me a list of
parameters I can supply to
make this API call.
And it also tells me which
of those are required.
In this case, I'm performing a
query to search all public
activities on Google+ that
match a query string.
And the query parameter
is required.
So, for example, if I click and
search for Google IO and
execute this request, I see that
the Explorer tells me the
request that was sent and the
JSON object with the response
from the API.
If I need to narrow it down to
my own activities, I can try
the list method in the
APIs Explorer.
plus.activities.list will list
all activities in the
specified collection, which is
in this case, activities for a
particular user.
The documentation for the
Google+ API indicates that to
list your public activities,
you can use a parameter me.
And you can use public
for the collection.
So let's try that and
see what happens.
When I click on Execute, the
APIs Explorer will tell me
that something has not worked.
The Explorer is indicating to
me in several ways that
there's a problem
with my request.
First, it is telling me that I
need to be authenticated in
this red bar.
And that I need to authorize
my request using OAuth 2.
Second, the API itself has
thrown a 401 HTTP response
code and the JSON object
specifying the error.
It looks like we need to pass
our credentials using OAuth 2
so that the Explorer can
fetch data for my
activities on my behalf.
So let's go ahead and try to
make a call with the APIs
Explorer that uses OAuth 2.
I would first switch to make
authorized calls using this
convenience switch
on the right.
The Explorer will ask me to
select OAuth 2 scopes.
These are used to specify levels
of access that will be
granted to the Explorer when
it accesses end user data.
I see that there are two
possible scopes that can be
used for this API call.
One for the Explorer to have
access to my + profile and one
for the Explorer to have access
to my email address.
I will select the
default option.
You can always look up the
documentation for an API to
see which scopes are declared
by an API, or read the OAuth
protocol documentation
for more information.
When I click on Authorize, I see
that now I get a consent
screen asking for end user
permission for an application.
In this case, the Explorer.
The Explorer wants to have
access to my data.
When you build applications that
make API calls to fetch
end user data, your end users
will see something like this
if you use the OAuth
2 protocol.
If I allow access and make the
same API call again, I will
see that now the APIs Explorer
actually fetches my public
activities from my profile.
To recap where we are up to now,
we have learned about two
tools to explore the
functionality of Google APIs,
the Google Developers Portal and
the Google APIs Explorer.
So we just did an authenticated
API call.
What if we want to learn
a little bit more about
authentication?
Let's start with an impossibly
brief summary of OAuth 2.
In a nutshell, OAuth 2 is a
protocol that allows you to
build applications that access
data on behalf of a logged in
user without requiring
their passwords.
The protocol consists
of a few steps.
An application makes a request
to Google to show the end user
a consent screen, just the way
we saw with the APIs Explorer.
On consent, Google gives access
credentials back to the
application.
The application then uses those
credentials to request
end user data.
And it's important to know that
the credentials expire or
can be revoked at any time
by the end user.
There's good documentation
on OAuth 2 on the Google
Developers site.
And there's a session on Google
I/O that dives deeper
into how it works and how you
can use OAuth 2 in different
platforms and use cases.
Luckily, the Google Developers
Portal also has a tool to help
you understand how OAuth 2 works
if you want to make an
authenticated API call.
This tool is called the
OAuth 2 Playground.
And it allows you to understand
the OAuth 2
protocol, and also navigate
the steps to make an
authenticated call using
an interactive tool.
You can actually make API calls
using this tool and
examine the HTTP response.
Let's try to recreate the steps
we just learned about
with the OAuth 2 Playground.
First we select which
APIs we want to use.
In this case, the Google+ API.
This will select an appropriate
scope for me.
If we recall from the few steps
ago, a scope defines the
level of access that an end
user will consent to when
given access to an
application.
When I click on Authorize APIs,
we're performing step 1,
which is the application.
In this case, the OAuth
Playground sending a scope and
requesting an authorization
code.
And see, I see a consent screen
similar to the one I
saw from the APIs Explorer.
This time the OAuth 2
Playground is asking
permission to access your
Google+ profile using the same
scope as before.
Once I allow access, the OAuth
2 Playground will actually
show me the HTTP requests made
to the OAuth endpoints at
Google and their response.
In this case, an authorization
code.
The next step is to exchange the
authorization code for an
access token.
The OAuth Playground allows you
to do that with a single
click of a button.
And it will also show you the
HTTP request that was made, as
well as the response.
In this case, an access token.
The OAuth 2 Playground actually
allows you to make a
call with those tokens.
Using the same example as
before, I'm going to list my
public activities from my
Google+ profile using the same
URI I used before.
If you recall, all we have to do
is substitute me and public
for the collection.
Once I send that request,
I see the
same response as before.
Unlike the APIs Explorer which
provides a directory of
methods, parameters for an API,
the OAuth 2 Playground
focuses on understanding the
steps in the OAuth 2 protocol.
When we used the Explorer, all
of these steps to request and
exchange tokens were implemented
behind the scenes.
Your client application would
have to do the same if you
write it from scratch.
The good news is that the Google
Client Libraries do all
this work for you, and implement
these steps under
the covers.
This is one of the many reasons
we strongly recommend
using the Client Libraries.
All right, we just saw how OAuth
2 Playground allows you
to learn about authentication.
What if you want to build an
application and make a request
using your own credentials?
When building an application
that uses Google APIs, you
need to obtain credentials
from Google which you can
embed in your API calls.
These credentials allow you and
Google to know who or what
is invoking the API.
And in some cases, can be used
in the OAuth 2 flows to
identify both the invoking
application and its end user.
Among other reasons, this
enables you to manage
application access.
Using the APIs Console, which
we'll talk about in a moment,
you can generate OAuth 2 client
IDs and API keys.
Which you can then embed in
your application to invoke
authenticated Google
API calls.
Use OAuth 2 client IDs in your
browser, desktop, or
mobile-based applications to
allow it to call Google APIs
and request data on behalf
of its user.
In our example, you would use
the OAuth 2 client ID if the
application caused the
Google+ API to fetch
an end user's data.
Use API keys if your application
does not require
end user data or consent.
For example, you might use API
keys in an application that
involves the Google Translate,
or Custom Search, or the URL
Shortener APIs.
The APIs Console is a management
tool for using
Google APIs.
Here, you can take a variety
of actions in addition to
generating OAuth 2 client
IDs and API keys.
For example, you can establish a
relationship with Google and
identify your application.
You can sign up to use Google
APIs and review
their terms of service.
You can obtain credentials
you can embed when
you make API calls.
And you can provide billing
details to use paid APIs, such
as those that are part of the
Google Cloud platform.
Now back to my application.
I'm going to use the Google APIs
Console to register an
application.
I'm going to give a name
and a simple logo.
And I'm going to sign up
to use the Google+ API.
And last but not least, I'm
going to obtain a client ID to
make API calls using OAuth 2.
When you go to the Google APIs
Console, you'll notice that
you're asked to create
a project.
Projects are used to identify
applications and assign
attributes to those
applications, such as
credentials, the team working on
them, traffic controls, and
others as we will see.
I'm going to create
a new project.
The next step is to sign
up for the Google+ API.
To do this, I simply turn
on the switch for
that particular API.
But notice how I can
use multiple
APIs in a single project.
When I sign up for this API,
I must accept the terms of
service before proceeding
forward.
I will only be required to do
this once as a developer, even
if I create other projects
that use the API.
Also, many Google APIs are under
a standard set of terms
of service, which means
you only have to
agree to these once.
OK, now I need to get
credentials for my
application.
The API Access tab on the left
side of the console allows me
to do just that.
So if I go to the API Access,
you will see that I can create
OAuth 2 client IDs
or API keys.
In this case, I will create an
OAuth 2 client ID since I want
my application to access data
on behalf of an end user.
When I do that, I will be
required to provide
information about
my application.
Providing a name
and [INAUDIBLE]
logo is enough for this step.
So I'm just going to call it
my killer app and give it a
funny logo.
Now I'm asked which type
of client ID I need.
As we saw before, there are
different types of client IDs
depending on the nature
of my application.
I will choose an installed
application since my code
lives in my own server.
When I do that, the system will
generate a client ID and
a client secret for me.
Now we have learned how we can
use the Google APIs Console to
obtain credentials and identify
your application.
We will now learn how to manage
access and traffic for
this application.
And why do you care about access
and traffic controls?
First, you may want to restrict
who can make calls
with your credentials.
This is your first line of
defense against leaked or
stolen credentials.
Depending on your use case,
the console allows you to
configure, for example, which
websites can invoke Google
APIs directly from a web browser
if you're working with
a browser key.
Which JavaScript origins are
allowed to make authenticated
calls using your OAuth
2 client ID.
The allowed redirect URIs to
be directed to after an end
user consent screen.
Second, you can throttle the
amount of traffic your
application handles.
This allows you to cap the
number of API calls initiated
by the end user.
This is particularly important
if you want to limit specific
end users from consuming all of
your available API quota.
Or if you want to cap the number
of API calls your end
users make against the
paid Google API.
For example, the Google
Translate for which you're
paying for.
So let's go back to the APIs
Console to work with this
simple example.
I'm going to go back to
the OAuth Playground
we were using before.
One of the advantage of the
OAuth 2 Playground is that it
allows you to enter your own
credentials, essentially to
pretend that the OAuth 2
Playground is your own
application, and to see what
your end users would see on a
consent screen.
So the OAuth 2 Playground
provides a place where I can
enter my own credentials.
And it's telling me that in
order for the flow to work, I
need to make sure that the OAuth
Playground URL is on the
list of allowed redirect
URIs for my project.
This means that once Google is
done presenting the end user
with a consent screen, it will
redirect to that URL.
And I'm going to copy it.
Now I can go back to the APIs
Console and generate a client
ID for a web application since
the OAuth 2 Playground is a
web application.
I will add the OAuth 2
Playground URL to the list of
valid redirect URIs for
this particular key.
Now, the APIs Console has
generated another client ID
and another client
seeker for me.
In this case, for a
web application.
We can copy now our own client
ID and client secret and paste
it into the OAuth
2 Playground.
So I'm going to take the client
ID, paste it in the
space for it, and take the
client secret and do the same.
Now we have a working
application that uses our
credentials.
And let's look how I would
configure traffic controls.
I can go to the quotas tab of
the APIs Console and set the
per user limit for API calls
that are made using my
credentials.
I see that the Google+ API
allows me to do 10,000
requests in a day.
And that I can further scope
that to a per user limit,
thereby allowing me to limit
traffic for individual users
and Queries Per Second, or QPS,
to limit individual users
from generating unwanted
traffic and
consuming all my quota.
I will set the value
to the default.
Let's go back to the OAuth 2
Playground and execute the
same steps as we did before.
I will select the Google+ API
and authorize the scope.
And now I see a consent
screen that is
presented as I expected.
But this time it has my
application information
displayed to the end user.
Then, once I grant access, the
application will continue to
make authorized calls
on behalf of me.
I can continue with the steps as
before and make an API call
the same way we did before.
And I see that the response
looks the same as before.
But this time it's coming from
the OAuth 2 Playground
pretending to be
my application.
I can also use the Google APIs
Console to check the traffic
for my application
and the traffic
that's being generated.
I can do that by looking
at the Reports tab.
The Reports tab contains useful
information about usage
patterns for your application.
In this case, I see that a
single API call, which I just
did, has been made using
my credentials.
We have now learned how the
APIs Console can help us
manage access and traffic
for our application.
And now that we have explored a
variety of tools and we have
signed up to use the Google+
API, let's build
and run some code.
Google makes it easy to get
started coding when using APIs
by providing a variety
of client
libraries in many languages.
Using Client Libraries has
many advantages, and we
strongly encourage
you to use them.
First, the libraries make it
very simple to securely call
any RESTful API and manipulate
the data without the need to
write any code to access the
data surfaced by the API.
The Client Libraries
also take care of
handling errors for you.
And most importantly, they
handle all of the steps and
the OAuth 2 protocol that
we learned previously.
Every time we introduce new
features to Google APIs, the
Client Libraries are gradually
updated to
include those features.
But let's not forget our
original objective, we're
building an application to
access the Google+ posts for
the user logged in
using the app.
Going back to the documentation
for Google+, the
client libraries are accessed
using the downloads link on
the left nav.
The downloads page has a table
with all the client libraries
currently available to
use with Google APIs.
These Client Libraries are all
open source and were developed
using the Google API Discovery
service, which was the same
service used to build
the APIs Explorer.
Let's click on the Python
Client Library.
This will bring us to an open
source project hosted on
Google that contains downloads,
documentation, and
more for the Python Client
Library for Google APIs.
I'm going to go ahead and
install this Client Library on
my server, for which I would
download a zip file provided
in the page.
Installing the Client Library
is as simple as running a
single command.
I will copy this command
for reference.
I'll also download
the zip file.
Notice that when you install the
Python Client Library, you
do not have to download
the zip file.
But I'm only doing that to
access some samples and
documentation included
in the bundle.
I have downloaded the
installation zip file and I
have placed it in a temp
directory on my server.
Now that I have done that and
extracted it, I can install
the Client Library using
a simple command.
And that's it, the Python Client
Library for Google APIs
has been installed
on my server.
Getting a starter application
running is just a matter of a
few simple steps.
We have already installed the
client library, we need a
sample that works with
the Google+ API and
is written in Python.
You can access samples from the
search box in the Google
Developers Portal from the
documentation for a particular
API, or from the open
source project that
hosts a client library.
Let's try to find a sample on
the open source project for
the Python Client Library.
If we go to the page,
we'll see that
there's a link for samples.
And it will give a list of all
Google APIs that have samples
in this client library.
By clicking on Google+, it'll
show me the path for the
sample for Google+.
So let's look at that sample.
It says it loops over all the
user's activities and prints a
short snippet.
There's a sample that does
exactly what I need it to do
in principle.
I see that the sample
comes under the
directory samples plus.
So let's go look for it.
So I'm going to go to my server
and navigate to the
path where the sample resides.
And I see the sample.
Let's try to run the sample
and see what happens.
No luck.
The sample application is
telling us to please
configure OAuth 2.
And why?
Because the APIs making an
authenticated call to fetch my
data and I have not supplied any
application credentials.
Let's examine the file where
we can specify our
credentials.
According to this instruction,
it's clientsecrets.JSON.
When we look at that, I see that
the sample has a space
where we can provide, within our
own server, the client ID
and the client secret for our
application, which we already
obtained when we signed up
to use the Google+ API.
The Python sample from Google+,
as well as many other
samples offered by Google,
provides a convenient location
to make it easy to paste
your credentials.
Let's see what happens when I
paste my credentials in the
file that was provided.
I'm going to go to
the APIs Console.
And as before, I'm going to
copy my client ID and my
client secret.
This time I'm going to go to my
server and paste it in the
provided file.
I'm going to start by pasting
my client ID, and then paste
my client secret.
So let's try to run that sample
again and see what
happens now that we've pasted
our credentials into the
provided file.
The first thing you will notice
is that, as we learned
when we looked at the OAuth
Playground, your application
makes a request to access data
on behalf of the end user.
And the end user can grant
this access in a consent
screen, which we see here.
The consent screen shows data
for my application and is
telling the user that my
application is requesting
permission to know who
they are in Google.
Once that request is granted--
and as we saw when we played
with OAuth Playground, my
application will be given an
access token that will
continue to use when making
API calls on my behalf.
When I use the Python Client
Library, I don't have to worry
about implementing any of the
steps in the OAuth 2 protocol
since those are handled
for me.
Let's run this code again.
The code, as we know, is
fetching all my public
activities from Google+.
You will see that my application
already knows who
I am, and it's making API calls
using the same access
token, which it can do until
I revoke it or it expires.
Let's look at the code in
a little more detail.
To make authenticated calls,
initiate an OAuth 2 flow with
the functions provided
in the library.
All we do is provide the scope
of the API we want to use,
which we can easily obtain from
the documentation or the
OAuth 2 playground.
We're also specifying in the
code the location of the file
that contains our credentials.
To make calls to the RESTful API
using HTTP protocols, we
can use the HTTP lib 2 library
to construct an HTTP object.
Then we can call credentials
that authorize to modify my
new HTTP object, so that it can
sign my request with OAuth
2 credentials.
And here's the beauty of
the client library.
We can create a service object
that knows how to talk to the
API by using the build
function in
the Google API client.
We pass the name of the API we
want to use and the version,
as well as the authorized HTTP
object from the previous step.
And we're almost there.
The client library allows you
to access collections in the
API by simply calling the
name of the collection.
For the Google+ API, you can
call service.people to access
the people collection.
The collection object that is
returned has all the methods a
collection understands.
In this example, we're using the
get method for the people
collection.
We can also pass parameters
to the API call.
Here we see how we constructed
another HTTP request object
that queries the activities
collection
and the list method.
A call to
service.activities.list does
not make the API call for me.
It only instructs an HTTP
request object that contains
in it all the information
required to make the API call.
If you want to execute
the request, you
can just call execute.
Alternatively, you can gather a
set of HTTP request objects
and execute them
asynchronously.
When we execute this request,
the API will return a JSON
response that will be converted
to a Python object.
In this case, activities dock.
Any error code returned
from the API
will erase an exception.
Again, all of these details
are handled by the client
library for you.
So we just saw how we can use
the client libraries for
Google APIs to write and run
your code in minutes.
In summary, we just learned
about some of the tools for
Google Developers
to explore the
functionalities of Google APIs.
In particular, the Google
Developers Portal and the
Google APIs Explorer.
Then we learned tools that
can teach you about
authentication.
In particular, the OAuth
2 Playground.
Then we saw how to obtain
credentials and identify your
application for which we use
the Google APIs Console.
We also saw how we can use the
console to manage access and
traffic for your application.
And last, we saw how you can
use the Google Client
Libraries to write your
code and get started.
For more information, you can
type the names of the tools we
just covered in the Google
Developers Portal in the
search box, or you can
go to the links
provided on the screen.
There are several sessions that
touch on how to build
applications that use Google
APIs in Google I/O 2012.
In particular, there's a session
that covers how to
build JavaScript applications
that use Google APIs.
In addition, there's a session
on how to optimize your code,
a session on OAuth 2 and
identity and data access, and
a session on building Android
applications.
Check the schedule for Google
I/O for dates and times.
And thank you very much, and
thank you for watching.